okay are we on sounds like we are so
welcome everyone
thanks for coming along nice to see a
solid crowd sorry i had to get that one
out of the way early
um i have to confess i've not been going
to any of the other talks yet so far
today so i haven't seen the other
speakers have they all been saying about
how great it is to actually be talking
to real people again
uh not that talking to pixels was was
that bad but
they're pixels anyway so yeah good to
see you all here
thanks for coming so i'm phil nash
uh some of you
may know me from previous talks where i
will have had a jet brains logo in the
bottom corner you'll see it's changed
because i'm now working at some nussels
i've even got the t-shirt because he's
staying a little there
so because i've used up all the red on
my t-shirt please don't use any of the
red tokens on the way out there's a bit
of a shortage now
okay we're going to be talking about
solid that we're going to be revisiting
it
and this is actually the second time
i've done this talk so really it should
be solid revisited revisited but that's
actually a later slide we'll get to that
um
if the talk title does sound familiar
though i do apologize we did have a bit
of a name clash with tony van nerd who
uh who gave a keynote c plus plus now
earlier this year with exactly the same
title it's not the same it's completely
different it's got a comma in the middle
that's how you can tell it apart but um
yeah we do cover
not the same material
similar idea but very different
direction so if you have seen that talk
this will be very different and if you
haven't you should go and watch it
because that's an excellent talk as well
which does actually go to show you know
this is a an idea whose time has come
revisiting the solid principles quite a
few people that have been questioning
are these things that we should be
uh teaching uh if not following uh and
what should we be doing instead and in
fact
this talk is actually drawing on at
least two other talks and i'm going to
do sort of a meta review of those as
well
so just just go to show there's a lot of
people thinking about this
and the subtitle say to the mata bit of
a play on words we'll
can revisit that a bit later as well
what i mean by that
but let's get off to a solid start
now if you were
just say doing a google search to try
and work out then what the solid
principles really are where should you
get started
you might hit this post by
bob martin which is a good start because
it's really bob martin that compiled the
solid principles in the first place
with some nuances we'll get to that
and the title is getting a solid start
seems like exactly the right place
this is from 2009 it's a little bit old
now but
uh it does say you know i'm often asked
how should i get started with the solid
principles great that's what i want
given the recent interest and
controversy
about the issue so even back in 2009
there's a little bit of controversy i'm
not even sure what that was now
um so it's probably time to give a
written answer
but then it goes on to say
you can read about the solid principles
here
and give us a link the paper i wrote
nearly a decade ago
that's where you get the first problem
because if you follow that link
you come to
to this site
which is uh choose vacation rentals
so unfortunately the object mentor
domain is no longer owned by the same
people so it's been a bit link checked
now so yeah it shows you that some of
this stuff's getting a bit outdated so i
used the wayback machine to find what
the original link was pointing to
it's uh it's this article design
principles and design patterns
by uh by robert martin
and
it's a it's quite a good paper this time
and it does go into a whole set of
design principles and then also a whole
set of design patterns you know two
separate things that will become
important later
the principles it goes into there
are these ones
um we won't go into the full names right
now we're just looking at the letters
that you might try to refer to as the
old durka cass principles if you're
really going for it
but you can sort of see
the start of what became the solid
principles there the first four
letters
themselves the oldie principles so
it also tells you a little bit about
them that they've been around for a
while
and a little bit later you know here i
did srp to that list
to get well
the saudi principles
still not quite there yet
then he wrote this book in
2002 2003
agile software development again
principles and patterns
and also practices
and there's a whole chapter there what
is agile design
where he lists
in exactly that same order the
effectively the soldier principles so
what we now think of as a solid
principle still hadn't quite been born
yet but
they were there this is this is where
they came from
there is a point to where this is all
going by the way but it's an interesting
bit of history
so
a few years later 2005 he wrote another
article
uh maybe a little bit harder to read on
this screen
but the principles of od
or as i like to call it the principles
of ood
this rolls off the tongue a bit better
and
you can see oh
i'm not ready for that bit yeah see at
the bottom there you can if you can read
it you've got
the same principles but now
they are in the order solid something
changed in the meantime
what's interesting is the article
doesn't talk about the solid principle
the talk doesn't mention them by that
name but they're at least in the right
order
what had changed in the meantime is
they'd have a discussion with michael
fergus
who pointed out that if he just
reordered the last two you do get a nice
acronym
so we really have michael feathers to
thank for that
um
but they they won't actually mention in
the paper and in fact he does also go on
to talk about those other principles
that were in his original paper so now
the um solidification principles
so
yeah we still haven't distilled it down
to solid principles this is where it's
at
but that came
some time after 2005 i never quite
pinned it down certainly by 2009
so we're sort of building up a little
bit of a of a timeline now just to put
that into historical
context
we've been talking about it from 2005 to
2000 and sorry 2000 to 2005 here
um and you know the rest as they say is
history
but also a bit of pre-history because he
didn't invent the underlying principles
they were drawn from earlier material
going back to 1979.
tom demarco
wrote a structured analysis and system
specifications
where amongst other things he talks
about the concept
of cohesion
things that belong together should be
together and the things that don't
belong together should should be a part
was the basis of srp well we'll talk
more about that later
bertrand mayer in 1988 object-oriented
software construction
introduced the open close principle
also in 1988 barbara liskoff
in data abstractions and hierarchy
introduced her substitution principle
that we now think of as the list of
substitution principle
and then the last two
well you can find them in a series of
papers between 94 and 96 by bob martin
in the c plus report uh so he sort of
gave them the names that we had now
but um they were still drawn on earlier
material but i couldn't quite trace back
the origins so
we'll give those ones to him
and interestingly if you put those up in
chronological order
bear in mind a little bit of ambiguity
about those pairings you can actually
get the solid principles out of that as
well so
yeah although they've only really been
around since 2005 or later they have a
long heritage back to
1979 so maybe the aldi principles was
actually getting at something
so perhaps some of these are a little
bit outdated we'll look at that later
but
interesting bit of history just to put
it all into context
so
okay we've been talking about the solid
principles but what actually are they
in fact who here
or who here's heard of the solid
principles
so almost everyone
uh which is not surprising given you
come to this talk
but of those people
who could honestly say they know what
each one of the letters stands for
even less than i than i thought are not
those who could actually accurately
describe the meaning behind each one of
those
this
is part of the problem
everyone knows that they're supposed to
be important we just don't really know
what they are
so let's have a quick recap not really
it's not going to be an introduction to
the solid principles uh that would be at
least the whole talk on its own in fact
klaus eagleburger who's who's here at
the conference has done such a talk
and i'll give you a load of references
at the end which um
which included a link to that
um but let's just recap at least from a
high level so we don't know what we're
talking about so
srp
and usually i get the audience to try to
suggest these but
i'm not used to being back in a big
crowd so i'll just go for it on my own
um
srp single responsibility principle
probably the most well-known one
that's a good thing i would say it's the
most important one
it's also the one that's hardest to get
the meaning from from the name
uh as we'll discuss
but
yeah one of the questions really is what
is responsibility
that there's talk of it being like a
reason to change
but then what does that mean as well you
keep asking questions and we will do
we'll come back to that
but yeah single responsibility if you're
going to stick to one that should really
be it just maybe give it a better name
ocp the open closed principle
most people have heard of that a few
people really know what it actually
means
um but we do say you know open for
extension and closed form modification
but how does that really apply
and
how does that really fit in with the the
agile mindset of embracing change if
you're closing for modification
does that actually fit as an agile
principle it was in the agile book after
all
we'll have a look at that
lsp
is the liskov substitution principles as
we mentioned earlier big problem there
is it's named after a person which
doesn't tell you a lot um what we're
going to do is substitution
substitute ability substitutable types
um okay that's good but again a lot of
people talk about this without really
knowing
what it meant and what most people take
it to mean now
so we'll have a look at that as well
the interface segregation principle is
next
uh all i say about that for the moment
is you can think of it as just a single
responsibility principle but applied at
the interface level
uh to first approximation
and then the dependency inversion
principle
uh we'll dig into that quite a bit but
um i think the biggest problem is that i
keep calling it the divinity injection
principle and i know i'm not the only
one
so we'll touch on all of those again
and say we're not going to go deep on
each one we're going to discuss problems
around them so
to
set the scene
i want to
bring up the first of the
the talks i'm going to do like a meta
review of
um
the first one that really got me
thinking about this stuff
so back in 2016 at a another ndc
conference in london
in dc london
kevin henny
gave this talk solid deconstruction
as you can tell from the title he
deconstructed the solid principle
you could say tore them down it wasn't
quite that that bad but he certainly did
pull them apart
and then
examine some of the problems that he had
with them uh we'll look at some of those
in a minute
there's another talk i want to introduce
it was actually a lightning talk
by dan north
with the um
maybe slightly over the top title of why
every single element in solid is wrong
but it certainly gets you thinking
it was a lightning talk and i couldn't
find a recording of this online just the
slides
so i may have missed some of the nuance
but i have talked to dan about it since
i think i've
i've captured it okay
so
um
interestingly
both of these presenters have also
proposed their own
acronyms
for collections of principles
uh but uh well in kevin's case maybe a
little bit tongue-in-cheek
because he's obviously trying to have a
play on solid so he came up with the
fluid principles
well he had always assumed that it was
meant to be taken tongue-in-cheek until
i was talking with kathleen about this a
few months ago before the accu talk
and he said no no i meant it seriously
um so
well you'll see for yourself we'll have
a look at them a bit later
and in fact i think
it can be a quite a nice exercise to go
away and try to come up with your own
acronym see what principles
you you think are the most important
and how i held together and
you might be surprised
what sort of lines of thinking that that
takes you down
now
the first time i started putting this
material together not as a talk but as a
rather interactive thing at the um
extreme tuesday club
usually in london it was online this
year
um earlier in february i think
uh and i got kevin and and dan along i
had a nice big discussion about it and
then said yeah i've been working on
an acronym as well but i'm not ready to
publish it yet so i couldn't reveal it
at the accu conference but i can tell
you now
that he has the cupid principles and he
does mean this quite seriously um
unfortunately i didn't quite get around
to putting a slide together with all of
the acronyms but i have put a link
to his article that he's posted about it
uh since so you can look that up
at the end
um it definitely takes it off in a bit
of a different direction
um okay let's have a look at
his talk though
uh let's put up the first slide from
there where he talks about the single
responsibility principle
which he calls the pointlessly vague
principle this sort of gets at the
essence of why it's
not a particularly good name it sounds
right
it's like yeah i agree with that
but when you pull it apart it let's say
what is a responsibility anyway what
does it really mean by only a single
responsibility does that mean it's doing
two things that it
and that's its purpose that that has to
be wrong as well you give the example of
etl
um
and then also
this idea of it being
one reason to change which is often
provided as the explanation
well you know how can you predict when
something is going to change how do you
know
what things only have one reason to
change
so it raises a lot more questions that
it answers at least on the surface
so
he has a
an alternate
version of this
which is right simple code
which i think is also a little bit vague
but
he is onto something here
and he actually
fleshes out a little bit simple code is
easy to reason about
can easily do several related things
and
perhaps most importantly refactor until
it fits in your head
this is one of dan's favorite phrases
uses that lies it's a really great sort
of pragmatic way of thinking about
simplicity
if you can fit in your head
then it's probably simply enough and if
it can't then you've got to do something
about it because you won't be able to
reason about it
this idea of reasonability is all tied
up with it
i don't think it goes quite far enough
but i think this is actually a really
strong idea and in fact it turns out to
be his answer to all of them
right simple code
is his his central principle at least
until he came up with the cupid
principles
um but it was just a lightning talk
enlightening talks are often meant to
be provocative and make you think it
certainly does that
so
i'm not gonna
question him too much on some of the
over top over the top bits but i think
this idea of simplicity being
really the more fundamental principle
that we should be thinking about
but there's a lot in that we're
definitely going to explore that more
a bit later
all right we didn't really talk about
kevlin's talk so
what kathleen did
was he went through each principle
individually but in a bit more depth
than dan did because it's a longer talk
and
basically boiled down what the the
underlying principle was so srp single
responsibility principle
as we've already
discussed
basically comes from ton demarco's idea
of cohesion
and cohesion
is when
as we said things that belong together
go together but if they don't belong
together
but they shouldn't be together
but the flip side to that
the term that kevin introduces here is
adhesion
where you just stick things that don't
belong together
together and that's what a lot of code
looks like
that's it's ad easy this sticky code and
you can think of just putting your
fingers in and
pulling out bits of unreality code it's
quite a good visual
um so this idea of cohesion
well i still need a little bit of
explaining but it gets much more to the
heart of what we're really trying to do
when we talk about separating the single
responsibility or separating concerns is
the other way it's often described
so yeah kevlin agrees that this is
probably the most important principle
once you understand what it's really
about once you
seize out the cohesion
and then he talks about
the open close principle
um
well actually before he gets to to this
bit
he does talk about the historical
context
it came out in the 80s i mean it was in
the 1988 book so it's really based on
thinking from before that
um
things were a lot more expensive then
like it's more expensive to change code
particularly since
we didn't really have much in the way of
mainstream version control
i did actually look it up i think rcs
came out in 1982 so it was around
but i didn't hear about it until the 90s
i don't know about anybody else
so
yeah changing code was actually a very
expensive thing and you have to be very
careful
so you can see why the open close
principle
was very much about you know don't don't
change what you don't have to
think of ways that you can add to it to
regular change
um and that was that was a useful idea
then so
in that sense
it's definitely outdated
but there's a part of it that
is still relevant and that's the bit
that's captured here
first of all the idea of using
polymorphism
um not so much for the in the sort of
the way of reuse that we were thinking
about in the
80s and 90s but that's still valuable
um
but particularly this part don't publish
prematurely
because if you've got
um objects in your own code base
uh or your team's code base but you
control every usage of it
then you should feel free to change that
as much as you like
you know the agile
embrace change mantra
really applies there that's not a
problem
but as soon as you publish that
outside to someone you don't control
could be another team
it could be the rest of the world
something in between
then it's so much more harder so much
harder so much more expensive
to make a change
that's when
extending rather than changing is
usually the better strategy some sort of
versioning strategy and that adds a lot
of extra complexity so the more you can
push that off
the more you can stay in that change
everything world
the better
so that part of ocp
keplin thinks is definitely
something we should we should still
consider
it doesn't apply to everyone though but
but it's still a worthwhile principle
risk of substitution principle
he actually goes into quite a lot to
analyzing exactly what disc off wrote so
what it means and how it's not quite
what people usually think of but what it
really boils down to again is use
polymorphism that's the substitutability
bit but
carefully
at least that's the executive summary
really and this really came out in the
discussion at the extreme tuesday club
what he was saying was that
the political substitution principle
means when you implement something
polymorphically you also have to conform
to the same contract
it has to do exactly the same thing in
the same way
otherwise it's not substitutable and
that doesn't really fit with what a lot
of people use polymorphism for and a
very strict interpretation when we need
them things like if you add logging or
something like that that's going to
break
lsp
so this is like more relaxed version
that most people
strive for which you know does allow
some things but this idea of preserving
contracts
turns out to be really what
the discharge substitution principle is
about
just in the context of polymorphism not
necessarily inheritance-based
polymorphism either
because when barbara liskoff was talking
about it was in the context of abstract
data types
and not io at all so you can apply this
in a broad range of
applications
so
useful but
as a principle we can use
when we're designing software it mostly
boils down to use polymorphism carefully
consider the contracts
isp as we said earlier it's basically
srp for interfaces so
the interface segregation principle so
does it really add anything to basically
repeat that in a slightly different
context
maybe
but kevin wasn't convinced
and the dependency
inversion principle
again use polymorphism
but with interfaces
is really what it boils down to i mean
there's a bit more about why you're
doing that here you're trying to reduce
your exposure to dependencies that's
that's the purpose of it
but in practice but it boils down to use
polymorphism with interfaces
so you can probably already see
there's a bit of repetition here
things just have been restated in
slightly different ways do we really
need all of these slightly uh
archaic named
principles to to tease that out
and in fact i i sort of regrouped these
a bit
and really it sort of boils down to two
and a half maybe three underlying ideas
the first one being the idea of cohesion
that's definitely definitely central and
that applies to srp and isp as we've
said
but then
polymorphism and interfaces
it's
dependency inversion principle ocp
and
when when applied carefully
lsp
and then maybe this extra bit with ocp
about not publishing prematurely um i
don't know if it's really a principle
it's just a good idea i think i think
it's difficult to know where to draw the
line but
um
yeah this idea of internal redundancies
was a big part of of kevlin's criticism
as well as some of the
naming
and terminology and we'll dig into some
of that a little bit more later
so
when i first watched this talk i found
myself agreeing
with a lot of what kevin was saying
definitely the
general direction and ideas
um and that's really interesting
historical context and idea uh asides
but i didn't agree with everything
and in fact towards the end of the talk
and i didn't check whether we had sound
enabled but i've got subtitles anyway
um
this is typical of kevin's talks
they're not
well they're designed to make you think
not to do the thinking for you
just like damn norse talks in fact so
yeah if he did agree with everything
then he probably went wrong somewhere
so that was actually that was actually a
good result
now interestingly
um you can see in in the slide that's
showing here i've got a picture of a
book kevin happens to be a co-author of
uh that happens to be a design patterns
book so it's all full tied in but
this is another thing kevin likes to do
is take pictures of books that he owns
on on different surfaces around his
house
and they've been doing this for years
and i quite like the idea
so
i happened to be doing a talk at the
same conference on the same day in the
same room
and i had a slide where i was trying to
do the same thing but i didn't i wasn't
really reading physical books anymore so
i took a picture of my ipad
with an e-book
but the reason this is relevant is
because this talk
was about simplicity
it's called seeking simplicity within
the references
and i was trying to get at this idea
that simplicity was actually this
essential
central
principle that we should be striving for
that everything else sort of drops out
of
so yeah it's only looking back i
realized that was actually on the same
day
okay so we've looked at
talked by kevin
talked by dan north considered their
criticisms
uh maybe added one or two our own in the
process
does that really mean that the folly
principles have problems
um they're not the only ones as i said
there are there are many voices here
i've tried to collect and sort of group
all the different criticisms that i
found
in in other talks and blog posts and
things
i've come up with this list
most of them are actually covered in
those two talks which is why i
highlighted them
so
it's going to go through these
and have a look do they are they really
problems and if they are what can we do
about them
so the first one is and this is this is
one of kevin's claims they're not
actually principles
and this is kevin uh picking up the
words again and he likes to do that
it's always entertaining when he does
um
and he he actually quoted from the uh
oxford
english dictionary um i found a quote
from the cambridge dictionary that's
very similar
but in support of his argument
where it says that principles are a
basic truth
or a basic idea or rule
that explains or controls
how something happens or works
or a moral rule or standard of good
behavior
or fair dealing
and kevin
kevin's argument was well the solid
principles are none of these
they're not absolute truths
um they're not rules
and they have nothing to do with
morality
so are they actually principles
and
his conclusion was no
but the reason i quoted from the
cambridge dictionary here is because
there's another definition there
although it's actually to do with
something something in principle
where if you agree with or believe
something in principle
you agree with the idea in general
although you might not support it in
reality or in every situation
that actually seems to be a much better
fit
so what we're talking about with the
solid principles
they're a good general idea they might
not fit everything but you should always
consider them
what did bob martin actually mean though
playing with definitions here well in
that article we looked at earlier the um
getting a solid start he has a whole
section what do i mean by principle
so the solid principles are not rules
they're not laws and they're not perfect
truths it's almost as if you just read
that definition in the dictionary no
that's not what i mean
yeah it's like talking to kathleen in
the future
there are statements on the order of an
apple a day keeps the doctor away
it's a good principle it's good advice
but it's not a pure truth nor is it a
rule
so he was quite clear about what he
meant and it does actually fit
with the cambridge dictionary so i'm
actually going to let him off this one
but not completely
there's still a problem here
in the very next paragraph in that
section he says
the principles are mental cubbyholes
they give a name to a concept so that
you can talk and reason about that
concept
which is a really powerful
um
thinking technology but
it comes with a price it's got a
downside and that's that when you give
something a name
people start to forget what the broader
discussion around it actually was
and they just had their own ideas about
what that means and they stopped
challenging it
and this happens time and time again
it's very difficult to get away from
this
that's happened with agile itself we now
talk about big agile and little agile
because they diverge so much
so by giving names to these things and
not just a name but this like catchy
acronym that everyone now talks about
started to become part of that problem
and perhaps even worse
they're not very good names
which is the next problem
that they're not particularly accessibly
named we can't really
look at those names most of the time so
yeah i know what that means
you do have to dig a bit more so
the single responsibility principle
well we've already discussed that i
think it's it doesn't really tell you
what you need to know you can't act on
it
as written you have to really understand
really it's about cohesion
separation of concerns and what that
means
so
yeah maybe one of those other terms
would have been better it was based on
cohesion in the first place anyway could
have stuck with that
the open close principle
i mean it sounds simply enough but again
now you have to start looking at
historical context and
even bob martin actually changed the
meaning of it from what bertrand mayer
originally meant
uh particularly he was talking about um
bertrand mayor was talking about not
just classes and objects but functions
and modules and all sorts of entities
but
bob martin was just talking about
classes here
and just talk about class hierarchies
really
so
we have to dig into it to really really
get out of it and then the whole thing
about
um
not um
not publishing prematurely
well
most people missed that completely
i did until i'd watched um cleveland's
talk on it
so yeah could be better named
similarly list cross-substitution
principle
we've said before yes named after a
person that never really helps
um
okay it's got the word substitution in
there we know it's to do with
substitutability but
what what makes it list of
substitutability
what's the difference now you have to
just have to know
and even the people that do know often
get it wrong so
yeah not very good name again
an interface segregation principle
it's not bad as a name in
that it's misleading
it's just unnecessarily grand i think
for a very simple idea that's just the
derivation of another principle anyway
so
not so bad but could be better
and then the dependency conversion
principle
quite apart from the fact that it's very
easy to say the definitive injection
principle
it's another one that almost obfuscates
what it actually means you could just
say program to an interface
and it will tell you
what you need to know
okay it doesn't quite get at the why
but dependency version is even further
away there's an even bigger problem with
it
and anyone know what these are
so john's saying
to to flip what you can see i think with
his hand gestures yeah so glasses that
you can wear that that flip
um your your
vision
um the question is why would you wear
these
and
the idea is that
um
as you probably know you know
are wired to our brain upside down so
the brain actually sees the world upside
down to begin with and the claim is for
the first few days of our lives we see
the world upside down
until the brain sort of
works it out
corrects and flips it and for the rest
of our lives
we see the road
the right way up
until we put these things on
we see it upside down again
but after a couple of days of doing that
it flips again
it's a really weird phenomenon but
apparently it's true i've never tried it
i think you have to be quite dedicated
to wear these things for a couple of
days
but as an experiment it's really
fascinating
the problem is that
as that bears out what inversion
actually means
means it's in a context inverted
compared to what
if you're inverting the upside down
world now it's the right way up
with dependency inversion
if you're inverting
what you have a dependency on but the
idea was that
we all depended on concrete
implementations mr theory
and we should invert that and depend on
the the abstract implementation instead
there's a little bit more to it but
it's changing what we were doing to this
new thing inverting it
but if we're now doing that as a matter
of course if we invert it we're going to
go back to the old ways so
it's a problematic name for several
reasons and unnecessarily so there's
just a really simple idea within there
that could be better named
so
that was naming
what about this idea of return internal
redundancy is that there's a big part of
kathleen's talk
um
yeah as he said there's just a couple of
ideas really there may be three ideas
for the push uh
spread out across these five different
principles
so
is that a problem
not necessarily
sometimes you need to just explain
things a different way or in a different
context before it really clicks
or sometimes it's not obvious that this
thing that applied over here also
applies over there
so
i don't necessarily have a problem with
that
um
the other problems may be but but this
one
i don't know if you look at
kevlin's fluid principles i would say
they have even more of this problem so
maybe we should be be careful what we're
complaining about um but yeah you could
you could actually list these much more
simply
i would say
all right what about
the fact that they're updated or some of
them at least they're outdated
we already looked a little bit
the open close principle
particularly the closed for modification
part it's open for extension and closed
for modification
and as we said you know in the
historical context of the 80s
so that doesn't really apply anymore in
fact since then we've had the agile
revolution where we're all about
embracing change so
i agree this part is outdated
but that's not the only interpretation
of it so
maybe it doesn't belong in there as a
dedicated principle because the main
part's outdated
and maybe even misleading but
the part about
you know premature publishing
as a little warning as an aside that's
fine so
um
yeah i mostly agree with him on this one
the dependency inversion principle
well as we just said you know it's a
reaction to the situation that was
around at the time
doesn't really apply anymore at least
don't worry that way
describe it in a clearer less ambiguous
way
so
i think the naming is outdated but maybe
not the the principle
um although there is another way that
you could say that the dependency
inversion principle is outdated and
that's uh
um
we don't
always depend on
interfaces now well
i imagine a lot of people here are c
plus plus
developers
this whole idea of everything being an
interface is not a big thing in c plus
plus we use interfaces or abstract based
classes but
not so much as say in the java or
c-sharp world i think even they are
changing there's this big push towards
um value oriented programming
so
maybe this is becoming a little more
dated anyway
the underlying idea is about dependency
management
that's still very valuable
but we don't necessarily do it through
interfaces
as much anymore
so
we're maybe i mean depending on which
community you're in
we are maybe in a transition period away
from this sort of thing or maybe we're
already there
so yeah there's some truth in that as
well
okay i miss those bits
yeah
about dependency management
okay another one is
that some of these are language specific
and most of them were formulated in the
context of c plus plus ironically even
though they're mostly applied
in java and c sharp
particularly
risk of substitution principle we think
of it as being about inheritance
hierarchies does it apply to dynamic
languages
well now we know what it's really about
substitutability and preserving
contracts we could say well it
definitely applies
you know if you've
got something that looks like a duck and
walks like a duck
but doesn't um
obey the contracts of a duck
is it still a duck
yeah i think lsp still applies even to
dynamic languages that's fine
um dependency inversion principle where
we talked a bit about how we're moving
away from
overuse of interfaces or heavy use of
interfaces as being our main way of
dealing with
dependencies
so
that's not so much language specific as
more sort of paradigm specific so
yeah it's debatable but i think let's
say c plus plus maybe a little bit
further ahead of the curve there
and isp interface segregation principle
same thing really
but when i forgot that again yeah
sorry
all right we talked about paradigms are
they just oo specific
and they are
painted as
object-oriented design principles
something should be a fair criticism and
in particular
functional programmers often say oh yeah
we don't
we don't need the solid principles there
are no everything
you know we we take care of all that
ourselves anyway
is that really the case
may be
possibly you could argue that
isp and dip the heavily interface based
ones are less relevant
although when i brought this up at the
accu conference somebody pointed out
that type classes
you can consider
in a similar vein to interfaces
uh still can apply there
something that's true
ocp
i think still applies to the data model
again in the limited way that it does
still apply at all
and
srp
i mean that always applies
you could argue that
most functional programmers almost get
that for free
because they're boiling everything down
to simple functions but you still have
to think about it
you can still write a
a function that just implements too much
and you need to split things out and
compose it
you've got better tools for doing it but
you still need to think about it
an msp
well it still applies to any sort of
substitutable types
so again you know things like type
classes but
also uh type erasure
um
concepts in c plus um or any form of
polymorphism not just dynamic
polymorphism
this applies to as we said it actually
was formulated in the context of
abstract data types not even
in the first place
so
yeah mostly it still applies
i mean maybe you do get more of it just
by following normal functional
programming practices but
it still applies
now
when i did this at the acc conference we
had a longer session
i did have a little bit reserved in the
middle for sort of more open discussion
um
i still got about
10 to 15 minutes more slides so
i think we'll skip this for now and if
we have time we'll come back at the end
to see what other people
people's thoughts are on on those
problems
but i'm going to carry on for now
to
the the second half
of my talk solid revisited revisited i
promised that slide maybe it should now
be revisited we visited we visited
but this is focusing more on that
subtitle
uh the state of the matter i said it was
a play on words this is the play
so
we talked about the fluid principles
kevlin's alternate set of principles
uh another play on words i also found
the liquid principles
in a blog post
so
one thing you can say about both of
these is they're not drying
don't repeat yourself
we didn't actually look what the fluid
principles were let's do that now
so
the f in fluid is functional
so what we just said a moment ago that
if you're following functional
programming practices
you tend to be getting a lot of the the
benefits of the solid principles anyway
so
yeah
i tend to agree with that anyway
for other reasons as well
then l for loose as in loose coupling
this is sort of the single
responsibility principle or part of it
so yeah that was always going to be the
most important principle so you've got
that now that's good
then we get unit testable
and
you sometimes hear people say
particularly they're doing tdd
that
by
driving my code from tests
um
i actually end up with something that's
more testable which sounds like a
circular argument but what they really
mean
is that code that is more testable tends
to
have all of those desirable design
principles baked in which is why the
solid principles are associated with
testing in the first place very often
they sort of go hand in hand
particularly
that loose coupling side of it so
yeah by looking at from that way round
how do i make my code more unit testable
you often get a lot of these principles
sort of dropping out of that
the downside is i sort of have to
already know them up front
that that's what the problem is
but okay i'll give him that and then
introspective
interesting one
i think it is a really powerful
way of of writing code but not saying we
have a lot of support for in most
mainstream languages yet this could be
sort of the next generation
of how we write code
um
and some languages do already have
better support for particularly compile
time reflection
and that sort of thing um
but i'm not sure quite there yet so i
don't know if i'll give him that one
at the last one he was definitely
reaching
for that final letter
and i'm not sure that item potent
is really a good design principle it has
its uses in some places but yeah i think
that one i think it just needed to
complete the acronym
so
i still think that this was
mostly meant plug-in cheek even if
there's some serious stuff behind it
as i said it's quite useful
to just pick some letters in an acronym
and see what design principles you can
come up with
and how important they are to you you
might might discover something
have a quick look at the liquid
principles
these are definitely meant to be
a joke or you can consider an empty
pattern
so
we want large files long classes and
methods interdependencies
all the codes are quagmire undocumented
illegible
and of course duplicate code
so yeah as i said definitely not dry
we laugh
but actually how much code do we work
with actually follows all of these
principles
so it's good to know what we're running
away from
so
this is obviously a play on like states
of matter
hence my subtitle
although technically fluid's not
actually a state
because
liquids and gases are fluids
what about the gas principles
i haven't seen anyone actually proposing
but i just think maybe like an overuse
of getters and setters
do it
maybe you can come up something better
um but of course we've also got plasma
that's a promising one
nice little rich set of letters there in
fact we'll come back to that
but you can go further
there's loads of exotic states of matter
and i looked them all up on wikipedia
i didn't get very far
coming up with the bo einstein
condensate principles but maybe you'll
do better than me but let's go back to
plasma
this is my attempt at coming up with a
set of principles that conforms to
letters that already there so
yeah it's uh
not necessarily
an absolute list but i think it's quite
quite good
so
we start with persistence
and what i mean by that is not
like writing to a file or database or or
just like keep going when when things
get tough but
like persistent data structures
and if you're not familiar with
persistent data structures think of
something like a simple binary tree for
example
um
say we want to add a new load like that
number four
in orange down there
in a classic binary tree we'll just like
mutate the parent mode and add it as a
as a reference
but
if instead you just copy
all of the the nodes up to the root from
there
and have each of those refer back to the
original tree
then now you've got two trees that have
shared
common state
so the original tree persists
where the name comes from
but you have a whole new tree as well
that looks like a complete tree
so this is a really useful way of
doing immutable data structures
while having all of the conveniences of
data structures that we know and you can
do this with lots of different types of
data structures
so if you really want to push
immutability as far as you can go you're
going to need to use
persistent data structures so it's a
really useful thing to to know about
but really this principle is a proxy for
immutability
strive for mutability where you can and
obviously there's gonna be places you do
need mutability but only use it there
not just by default as most languages
that we use
that offer
is the key
local reasoning is my next one
and this is another one that's
very much comes from the functional
programming world that's not limited to
it and it's also tied in with
immutability again but
think of an example like this so this is
some perhaps c plus plus code or even c
code
um
you've got a an enum for color
if you don't understand the spelling
that's that's what it says
and
to initialize it we actually need to
call some function to to work out some
condition
whether it's going to be yellow or white
in this case
it's oops it seems simple enough on the
surface sort of code you'll see all over
the place to not think anything of
it's got quality problems considering
that
first of all in terms of immutability if
you can't make
that color variable const
even if we're not going to change it
after that point
because we want to change it so that we
can assign to it
and because of that in order to assign
it you need to use an assignment
which is a side effect and in this case
it's an enum but if it was a more
complex data structure we might have to
initialize it in a temporary state
and then assign a new state to
afterwards there may be a performance
implication as well
so
it's actually not that good a pattern
what we really wanted to do if we had an
expression oriented version of c plus
plus in this case
then
we could write something like this where
the if was an expression
and then
that just evaluates to the value that we
can then use to initialize our variable
now we can make it const
but we can also
use type inference here as well
so we've got all these additional
benefits there's no side effects
it's great
of course we can do this today in
surplus plus and many other languages
using the ternary operator
so
we can do it to a limited extent
but that doesn't scale very well
uh we really need a feature like this
that i mean
functional programming languages tend to
look like this
but you can fake it
using
um immediately invoked lambda
expressions
so you wrap the expression in a lambda
that you immediately invoked and return
out of it
and that way you can
i meant to put the the slide up that had
that on it but
that way you get all of the benefits you
have here
in the language that we have today
so immediately vote lander expressions
give you fake expression oriented
programming
you heard it here first
what's this got to do with local
reasoning
well the reason i brought this up
is because in the mutable version to
reason about the value of that variable
you need to look at every line of code
that it goes through
because it can change any point
and until you've looked at the line of
code you don't know if it hasn't changed
that could potentially be the whole
program
and it very quickly
gets so difficult to track that it's
tall intense and purpose is impossible
so we give up
we think well the value is something
somewhere i don't know
um
i don't know if there's gonna be a
fretting problem or whatever
we can't reason about it anymore
local reasoning in this case means
well we can see the variable being
initialized we know now we now know what
the value is
for the rest of its lifetime
well apart from anybody being malicious
with contrast but
but that's local reasoning and it
applies in different ways it's just
about being able to look at a line of
code and reason about everything to do
with that bit of code
rather than having to consider every
other part of the program as well
the first a is for algorithms
and if you haven't seen sean parent's c
plus plus seasonings talk
where it talks about no role loops then
then you should do
um it's a bit c plus plus specific so if
you're not a super fast developer we
should watch it anyway because it's
really good but you may not get as much
out of it
but the point is rather than writing raw
loops use an algorithm that more clearly
expresses the intention
of what you're going to do
that saves you from all the complexity
of the loop
and
loops have this ability to look really
simple until you realize all the things
you missed
that's why algorithms
that have already been written and
tested by experts are almost always the
best approach so learn your algorithms
and if you are into c plus after
watching this go and watch connell
heikster's algorithm intuition talks
where he takes it to the next level
so use algorithms
never get to simplicity
so i said that i agreed that this was
probably the really the underlying
central concept and i did that whole
talk on it
seeking simplicity
but that talk was actually based on a
talk by well not based on but drew a lot
of ideas from a talk by rich hickey
made easy if you watch that one too
that's really good and one of the things
i stole from him was these illustrations
to illustrate what
the the etymology of simple and complex
is from uh from the original latin
a simplex
is
something with only one fold or braid
whereas a complex it's something funny
folds or braids
so really it's just to do with the way
things cross over or interweave with
each other
which makes sense
if you think about it
now if you look at
the
illustration on the left
the simple one if you took one of those
strands so from the bottom and they did
follow it to the top
absolutely trivial no problem at all but
try to do the same with the one on the
right
i'm obviously you can do it if you're
looking closely enough you'll have to
carefully follow it around to see where
it ends up and that's just with four
strands
this gets to this cognitive limit that
we have
um you may have heard the the uh the
magic number seven plus or minus two
like the limits of how many things we
can hold in our brain at once it's
related to that there's only a small
number of things that we can hold in our
brains for focus on at once
and once we blow that limit well we the
best we can do is resort to things like
chunking
which in programming call abstraction
so
things that cross over
are the things that have complexity
and in our code
that implies things like as we already
said mutable reachability
if something is mutable then you have to
consider every line of code it interacts
with so everything's crossing over
threading is the obvious one
globals and singletons
about any sort of dependency
you probably think of more as well i
don't have a list in front of me but
these are all the things that tend to
raise the complexity and if they're not
if they're in your code unnecessarily
you're relying unnecessarily complexity
in your code
so reducing
that
really answers all those other problems
you know you're going to reduce coupling
because that's complexity unnecessary
unnecessarily so
if you're dealing with threading make
sure you using approaches that make that
safer
and so on
don't use singletons or globals
everything drops out of that
i think this really
it sounds obvious but it's something if
you can keep like centrally
in your mind that these are the problems
will really help you to to write code
that just
as dan north said fits in your head
so i really do think that simplicity is
the key to all of this
we jump over to the last one
abstractions the other way um because
it's sort of related that i mentioned a
minute ago
probably called chunking in psychology
terms is basically abstractions in
programming terms are you probably
familiar with this quote from joel
sporsky
all non-trivial abstractions to some
degree
are leaky
this is a another slide from that talk
on simplicity
i've graded some bits out because i
think if you take those out it actually
makes the statement stronger
all abstractions are leaky
and i make a
a case for that in my other talk about
why even things like numbers are early
abstractions
so
there's a consequence to this
because abstractions as we said they're
our way of dealing with complexity
but they're a double-edged sword
because if they're leaky and all
abstractions are leaky
then the thing you're abstracting
with
gets intermingled with the thing you're
attracting you've actually increased the
complexity by trying to manage it
so
that can be problematic
and
well as george box says
all models are wrong but some are useful
so
yeah all abstractions
increase their complexity but some are
useful
how do we how do we navigate that
if it's not a problem you've considered
before
well it's another slide up all for that
talk and it didn't quite come across
well but
the first step is just to try and keep
those abstractions
as small and as simple as possible in
the first place but but from there
we then to go one of two ways and this
was
sort of my
key takeaway from this
because either we want what i i'll call
a global abstraction
and that's that could be something like
a language or a standard library
or just some really fundamental library
that you know everyone's going to rely
on
and reliability is the key there
we can never make it 100
um
complete
or watertight but that should be our aim
we want to
be be reliable not leaky as much as
possible
that takes a lot of effort and you'll
even then you won't get there
the other side is what i call local
abstractions think are just going to
using your own code base more as an
organization unit just to sort of manage
that complexity locally
very valuable but
embrace the fact that they are going to
be leaking
so
keep them shallow
don't don't try to have this sort of
overarching metaphor
in your code base it's just so easy to
get sucked into
that this means have you ever found
yourself debugging maybe even your own
code and think why do i have to go down
this little whole
chain of of cause just to get to the
thing that i know is actually there
it's because your abstraction is
actually complicating the whole thing
so we need abstractions
but if they're going to be leaky anyway
keep them sort of shallow and focused or
use existing ones that
have been designed to be as complete and
watertight as possible
so i think this is the best that we can
do
with attractions to take advantage of
them
looks like i'm running out of time so
i'll say very briefly about modularity
but um
i should change this from the accu
version it was memory safety there i
think modularity is a better fit so it
fits in better with the separation of
concerns
idea but um
i will
leave talking about that in depth
and just
go to the end
and say that all those references i
talked about are on my website level of
indirection dot com
slash refs slash solid.html
uh and if you don't remember that i've
also got extra level of indirection.com
that redirects there of course
but that is it so thank you very much
[Applause]
you